foreign
let's go to Kimberly in Charlotte North
Carolina what's up Kimberly how we doing
I'm doing good how about you fantastic
what's up
um so I have a question me and my
husband have just started watching Dave
Ramsey
um I am 26 my husband is 24. we make
about 105 000 a year before tax with our
debt free except for our house mortgage
and we want to start investing my
question is should we start investing
now or work on paying our house off
faster yes
that's it the answer is yes and you're
going to do both in baby step four five
six we do them all at the same time so
you kind of get one plate spinning with
baby step four let's start investing
fifteen percent of our income into
retirement you guys don't have kids
no not yet okay so we're gonna fast pass
Disney style through baby step five for
now and go to baby step six so any extra
margin beyond that fifteen percent you
can now throw on top of your principal
mortgage
okay
um also we have
um an eighty thousand dollar truck that
is paid off we paid off in a year and a
half holy drop Batman
does it fly yeah
um it was my husband's dream truck he
got it before we got married and
then his dream truck turned into his
dream wife and now the dream truck has
got to go away yeah all right I that's
what I think he doesn't want to get rid
of it but I would you recommend selling
that and putting that down on the house
or investing
this is me personally not owing owning
an 80 000 truck yes absolutely and our
advice when it comes to toys because
let's be honest an 80 000 truck is a toy
is not to have more than 50 of your
income tied up in things with motors in
them and it sounds like you guys have as
much income as you do toys
yeah what is your car worth
uh my car is worth like uh six thousand
okay hold on what kind of drone man will
allow his wife to drive drive a six
thousand dollar car while he drives an
eighty thousand dollar truck hold on let
me interject here Kimberly because
George drives a Tesla I'm just a John
this is beyond Tesla at this point no I
I understand I come from a truck driving
State a place where trucks are equal to
if not a little bit more important than
the spouse I get it
um there it is
um yes there is a I I I I know of trucks
that cost 80 000 cost a hundred ten
thousand dollars that are tools there
they have a utility to them oh I think
you're talking about the guys driving
them yeah I was like yeah
they have utility they're nice guys so
they are toys but they're also utility I
also know a whole bunch of dudes who are
a leveraged to their eyeballs to drive
an 80 000 truck when a used twenty
thousand dollar version of that truck
will last them for a long long long time
and as George mentioned
you guys don't make enough money to
justify having an 80 000 depreciating
asset in your driveway
has been convinced of it well
here's the the way to do it this is not
going to be a math problem uh it might
be it could be but this is a
I'm scared that we don't have an
emergency fund and you have an 80 000.
oh you do okay this is we do
um I want to be in a home
I want to start thinking now about what
our life is going to look like in five
years in 10 years and in five and ten
years you're going to have a forty
thousand dollar truck sitting in the
same spot in the driveway and we're
still not going to have a down payment
on a house
I'd love to see you sell that 80 000
truck while people still are still
paying crazy amounts of money for used
trucks and go buy a nice go buy a nice
thirty thousand dollar truck that's used
that's got mileage on it everybody's
gonna live and let's take fifty thousand
dollars and put that down on our house
what's left on your mortgage yeah
pardon me what's left on the mortgage
uh about two
two uh well we definitely just bought in
August it's like 2 20 I think okay
2015 years forget 15 years you guys you
guys have a life to live I don't want to
be in debt for 15 years do you
no so let's have a goal of five or seven
or ten at the most and what what is this
50k gonna do that goal it's going to
speed up that process by a lot yeah
definitely so think of it this way um
this has been a Hank
I grew up and we didn't have a lot
growing up and money was a was a hard
conversation and I didn't know a lot of
people with a lot of money for a lot of
my life and one of the ways
um when I now get to sit by Dave every
week I get to sit by people who think
about wealth differently and one of the
things they have taught me is to stop
thinking about money
in ways a B and C or D how can I get
this thing how can I see this how can I
can make the shiny thing even shinier
and here's a a unique take on money how
can I buy hours of my life
how can I buy back time
and so if you just look at your 105 000
household income that y'all make and you
think how long would it take us
to put to pay down fifty thousand
dollars of our mortgage
that might be one or two or three years
of your life
and we can buy three years of our life
two years of our life if we just go sell
this big dump truck
and changing the way I look at my life
now I actually went and bought another
mower because it took me six hours to
mow my place out in the woods on a
Saturday now me and my son do it
together and we get done at two I just
bought four hours of my life back you
see what I'm saying so yeah that's how
I've started shifting
um how can I I I've started paying for
things that I don't normally pay for but
I started thinking how could I buy hours
of my life back and I want you to sit
down with him and say hey we could
accelerate this by two years by three
years and then we can get a jump start
on our debt free life and bring a kid
into a world that doesn't know what a
mortgage even is and it starts with
selling your beloved baby out in the
driveway yeah
yeah I agree and we're all clear you get
the nice car next time right yeah
six thousand reason numbers 80 000. have
him call the show George and I want to
talk to him hey what color is the truck
I'm just curious what color is it
it is red I knew it John I was thinking
about it oh my God I had it for two
years and it's brand new like he keeps
that thing as soon as you called in I
was like big white [ __ ] I was like this
is a child who grew up and got money and
he wants a big white [ __ ] and hey he
doesn't have a mortgage on it so high
five to him but man
that's a lot sell the truck man you know
what I'm gonna challenge him I'm gonna
challenge you to find a ten thousand
dollar truck to get you to and from whoa
put down seventy thousand dollars on
your house
move that sucker dollar just accelerate
it man accelerate it buy back moments of
your life